♪ ♪
>> Greg: TODAY I’M JUST GOING
TO LIST SOME LAWSUITS ARISING
FROM THE PANDEMIC, BUT IT IS
STRAIGHT FROM
"THE WASHINGTON POST."
AIRLINES HAVE BEEN SUED OVER
GROUNDED FLIGHTS, TICKET BROKERS
HAVE BEEN SUED OVER CANCELED
EVENTS, INSURERS SUED OVER
COVERAGE LIMITS, GROCERS AND
INTERNET RETAILERS SUED OVER
RISING PRICES.
HOSPITALS OVER PROTECTIVE GEAR,
UNIVERSITIES OVER CLOSERS.
AMUSEMENT PARKS OVER UNUSED
SEASON PASSES.
SKI RESORTS, STRIP CLUBS HAVE
SUED FOR FEDERAL BENEFITS.
A CHURCH HAS BEEN SUED FOR
HOLDING SERVICES.
CRUISE LINES SUED FOR SAILING
WITH THE VIRUS.
BANKS HAVE BEEN SUED FOR HELPING
EXISTING CUSTOMERS FIRST.
GEMS FOR COLLECTING MEMBERSHIP
FEES.
WALMART FOR ALLOWING --
TARGET OVER THE EFFICACY OF
HANDS SANITIZER.
RIDE HAILING FIRMS SUED OVER
SICK LEAVE, AND MULTIPLE
EMPLOYERS HAVE BEEN SUED FOR
FIRING WORKERS COMPLAINING OVER
SAFETY MEASURES.
SO HERE’S A SUGGESTION, WHEN THE
LOCKDOWN LIFTS, EVERYONE GOES
BACK TO WORK EXCEPT THE LAWYERS.
SERIOUSLY, I THINK, THIS IS THE
FIRST TIME WE ARE STARTING A
CIVILIZATION WITH THE BURDEN OF
LAWYERS.
WHEN THE WORLD BEGAN, YOU DID
NOT NEED A REAL ESTATE LAWYER TO
BUY A CAVE.
THE WITCH DOCTOR DID NOT HAVE TO
GET TO MALPRACTICE.
THERE WERE NO RETELLS ON THE
WHEEL.
AND DO YOU THINK THAT WE WOULD
EVEN HAVE FIRE IF A LAWYER WAS
PRESENT?
SO TO GET US OUT OF THE HOLE
TODAY, TO RESTART CIVILIZATION,
WE NEED LAWYERS TO LIGHTEN UP.
CONGRESS SHOULD ATTACH LEGAL
IMMUNITY TO THESE BAILOUTS, SO
COMPANIES AND ORGANIZATIONS
DON’T GET RUINED AGAIN BY SOME
GUY WHO YELLED COUGH IN A
CROWDED RESTAURANT.
AND THEN WHEN THE ECONOMY
RETURNS, WE CAN GET BACK TO
SUING THE CRAP OUT OF EACH
OTHER.
THIS SEEMS LIKE A PLAN WE CAN
GET BEHIND EXCEPT THE LAWYERS,
WHICH MEANS IT’S GOT TO BE GOOD.
YOU KNOW, DANA, I OFTEN, I KNOW
THAT WE NEED LAWYERS.
IT KEEPS THINGS SIMPLE SO WE
DON’T GO DUAL WITH MUSKETS, BUT
HOW CAN WE EXPECT BUSINESSES AND
ORGANIZATIONS TO TAKE THE RISKS
AND OPEN IF SOMEBODY CAN POLL
THE MODERN SLIP AND FALL SAYING
THAT TODAY GOT SICK AT YOUR
ARBY’S?
>> Dana: IMAGINE THAT SOME OF
THE RESCUE MONEY THAT WAS JUST
PASSED BY THE CONGRESS HAS TO GO
TO ACTUALLY PAY FOR LAWSUITS
LIKE THIS, NOT TO KEEP PEOPLE ON
THE PAYROLL WHICH WAS THE
ORIGINAL INTENT.
SO I THINK THIS GOES BACK, MAYBE
NOT TO THE CAVEMAN DAYS, BUT
WHENEVER THERE IS A CRISIS, THE
TRIAL LAWYER START CHASING THE
AMBULANCES.
THIS HAPPENS ALL THE TIME.
AND THE REPUBLICANS FOR YEARS
HAVE BEEN TRYING TO GET TORT
REFORM PASSED IN CONGRESS.
THEY HAVE A STRONG RAPPORT WITH
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY, BUT THIS
IS A TIME WHEN YOU NEED TO
COMPROMISE.
SENATOR MITCH McCONNELL THIS
WEEK HAS BEEN TALKING ABOUT THE
NEED FOR THIS.
HE SAID THAT THE NEXT ROUND OF
SUPPORT MONEY FOR AMERICA WILL
NOT PASS IF THERE IS NOT SOME
SORT OF LIABILITY PROTECTION.
HE IS NOT SAYING THAT BECAUSE HE
WANTS TO GET TO THE LAWYERS,
NECESSARILY, HE IS SAYING THAT
BECAUSE IT IS ESSENTIAL IN ORDER
TO GET THE ECONOMY MOVING AGAIN.
COMPANIES ARE TOO AFRAID TO
START BACK TO WORK, THEY ARE
WORRIED ABOUT GETTING SUED, THEY
ARE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO DO
THIS PROPERLY.
NOW, THEY HAVE TO FIND A WAY TO
DO IT SO THAT COMPANIES STILL DO
WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE IN ORDER
TO PROTECT WORKERS AND ALL OF
US, LIKE, WE ARE NEVER GOING TO
BE IN TERMS OF KEEPING THINGS
CLEAN, ET CETERA, BUT THIS
LEGISLATION IS GOING TO PASS,
AND IS GOING TO HAVE LIABILITY
REFORM, AND I THINK THAT IT IS
FINALLY TIME THAT WE ARE GOING
TO GET A COMPROMISE ON THIS IN
WASHINGTON.
>> Greg: I’M NOT TALKING ABOUT
ALLOWING RESTAURANTS OR
BUSINESSES TO BE INCREDIBLY
CARELESS, THERE IS COMMON SENSE,
BUT I FEEL LIKE THERE NEEDS TO
BE AN INJECTION OF
REASONABLENESS, OF KNOWING, IT
WILL TAKE SOME TIME TO GET OUR
LEGS BACK IN THIS ECONOMY.
>> Juan: THAT IS ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT.
I AGREE 100%.
THE ONLY CAVEAT I THROW IN,
GREG, I THINK THAT YOU CAN’T
EXCUSE COMPANIES WHO SAY THAT
WORKERS, COME BACK TO WORK, BUT
THEN THEY RECKLESS OR NEGLIGENT
IN TERMS OF PROTECTING THOSE
WORKERS SO THAT PEOPLE DON’T GET
HURT, PEOPLE DON’T GET SICK.
THOSE COMPANIES SHOULD BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
I DON’T THINK THERE IS ANY
QUESTION ABOUT IT.
IN TERMS OF JUST BEING
REASONABLE, FORGET SLIP AND
FALL, WE JUST HAVE TO BE
REASONABLE WITH EACH OTHER,
BECAUSE WE ARE GOING THROUGH A
DIFFICULT TIME.
>> Greg: EXACTLY.
THERE NEEDS TO BE AN OFFICE OF
REASONABLENESS, JESSE.
WHICH YOU CAN ACTUALLY RUN IT,
AND SAY, LIGHTEN UP, EVERYBODY.
I KIND OF ADMIRE THE STRIP CLUBS
OF PRYING FOR FEDERAL BENEFITS.
>> Jesse: JUAN IS ALWAYS
TALKING ABOUT THESE PEOPLE
GETTING APPLICATIONS THROUGH TO
APPLY FOR THE LOANS, THEY ARE
THE ONES APPLYING FOR THE LOANS.
THE LAKERS APPLIED FOR A SMALL
BUSINESS LOAN.
AND HE BLAMES TRUMP, HOW ABOUT
YOU BLAME THE LAKERS.
BUT TO THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS
IN THE POCKET OF THE TRIAL
LAWYERS.
EVERY YEAR THEY DONATE OVER
$100 MILLION, 75% OF IT GOES TO
DEMOCRATS, THEY TAKE THEIR
PROFITS FROM SUING COMPANIES,
PLOW IT BACK TO THE DEMOCRATS.
AND THE DEMOCRATS GET REELECTED
AND DO NOT PASS REFORM.
THAT’S THE SHELL GAME THEY PLAY.
BUT THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
ECONOMIC PHILOSOPHY IS NOT WHAT
WE NEED RIGHT NOW.
THEIR PHILOSOPHY IS OVERBURDENED
AND OVER REGULATE SMALL BUSINESS
BUSINESS, AND KIND OF DOWNPLAY
CONSUMERISM, REMEMBER, YOU DON’T
NEED THIS EXTRA CAR.
WHY ARE YOU GETTING A TRUCK?
DON’T TAKE A VACATION.
HOW MUCH DO YOU REALLY, REALLY
NEED?
AND THEY MAKE SMALL BUSINESSES
GO OUT OF BUSINESS.
THEY ARE SUING THEM.
ACCUSING THEM OF DISCRIMINATION.
MAKING THEM COMPROMISE THEIR
RELIGIOUS INTEGRITY.
THAT HAS TO STOP.
ANNA WILL BE SET UP WHERE THE
LEFT IS HURTING THE RECOVERY,
AND DONALD TRUMP IS GOING TO BE
SAYING, HEY, LET’S UNLEASH THIS
THING, AND IT IS NOT A GOOD
THING TO BE AND IF YOU ARE A
DEMOCRAT.
>> Greg: KENNEDY, I AM
THINKING ABOUT SUING YOU FOR NO
PARTICULAR REASON.
>> Kennedy: SOLID.
ALL RIGHT, I WILL COUNTER SUE
YOU, HOW DO YOU LIKE THEM
APPLES?
IT BOILS DOWN TO SOMETHING VERY
UNSEXY, BUT VERY NEEDED.
AND THAT HIS RESPONSIBILITY, AND
THAT IS A TWO-WAY STREET.
YOU CANNOT JUST BLAME EVERYBODY
ELSE FOR EVERYTHING, ESPECIALLY
WHEN YOU CAN’T PROVE YOUR
GRIEVANCE.
SO IF YOU ARE IMMUNOCOMPROMISED
AND YOU ARE OLDER, DON’T GO
OUTSIDE.
DON’T GO BACK TO WORK.
AND IF YOU ARE AN EMPLOYER,
DON’T PUT YOUR EMPLOYEES IN A
SITUATION WHERE THEY CAN BECOME
INFECTED.
WE ALL HAVE TO HELP EACH OTHER
OUT.
AND THAT DOES NOT MEAN THAT WE
RUN BEHIND THE COURTS AS SOME
SORT OF SHIELD WHEN OUR ACTIONS,